la recommandation du hcsp du haut
conseil pour la santé publique et les
masques ffp2 la recommandation n'a été
remis ce week end je pense que nous
allons la publier ce soir ou demain et
vous verrez que c'est une recommandation
qui portent essentiellement sur les
soignants et qui je suis je résumais
l'avis du hcsp n'y avait pas vers une
extension du port du sfp de y compris
d'ailleurs dans le milieu des soignants
au delà des soignants qui sont
aujourd'hui considérées comme à risque
parce que exposait des gouttelettes
c'est la recommandation du hcsp le
gouvernement aura évidemment à se
prononcer nous allons discuter de cela
on rendra publique la vie vous verrez
qu'on est assez loin d'après le hcsp de
détendre le ffp2 à d'autres catégories
professionnelles
[Musique]